they told him
he wasn't wanted he didn't want to know
local officials said donald trump would
hinder the healing
he ignored their appeal not to come to
kenosha to this campaigning president
the political appeal was stronger they
just don't want us to come in
and then destruction is done a day early
we would have saved your story
one day early one day early so governors
have to call the mayors have to call as
soon as they call
the federal government will come in
it'll put it out the image was of
leadership and tackling unrest
but on this photo opportunity the
caption cuts both ways
a few blocks away this was the scene in
the street where jacob blake was shot
a community showcase with special guests
who've known a thing or two
about fighting racial injustice with a
word or two
for president trump he's not here to
record to uh console the families
he's here to uh give confidence to the
militia
make a young killer hero 70 year old
child
he should be the father of the country
he's operating at a very low moral level
security lined up for the family of
jacob blake they say they've received
death threats
but it won't deter a pursuit of justice
and we're not going to allow anybody to
take that focus away
from getting justice for getting shot
seven times in the back for our little
nephew little jake
that's what we're going to do as a
family and have you heard any buildings
burning lately in kenosha
no donald trump says the fallout from
what happened here
is a result of failing democratic states
and that a breakdown in law and order is
a vision for all
if he loses the election his opponent
joe biden
says that what has happened has happened
in trump's america
and that racial injustice is being
inflamed by the sitting president
this place has witnessed the worst of
america's unrest
since these scenes of violence last week
protest has been peaceful in kenosha
but it remains for now a prop
in this political fight